Donald Trump once again as he often does
gave one of these strange teleprompter
sort of coma speeches where he looks
visibly confused by the words on the
prompter which by the way still doesn't
keep him on message and jumped directly
on the Republican bandwagon of the last
48 hours of blaming video games for
violence in the real world
I played clips for you yesterday from
Fox News Texas lieutenant governor and a
Republican congressman Kevin McCarthy
blaming video games for shootings
blaming the violence within those games
for making people go out and commit
shootings in the real world and I told
you yesterday they are united behind
this talking point because they don't
want to take responsibility or
acknowledge Donald Trump's own rhetoric
and their fear-mongering about
immigrants for year after year after
year for being at least partially
responsible for shootings and violent
acts that we've seen of late here is
Donald Trump jumping on the bandwagon
bringing on bringing up video games
second we must stop the glorification of
violence in our society this includes
the gruesome and grisly video games that
are now commonplace it is too easy today
for troubled youth to surround
themselves with a culture that
celebrates violence
we must stop or substantially reduce
this and it has to begin immediately
Ethan Klein from the h3 podcast reminded
us of this clip which is just one
example in this one Donald Trump joking
and sort of playing around with the idea
of violence against immigrants to stop
them from coming to the United States
check out this clip and there are many
of these but how do you stop these
people you can't there's not
that's only in the Panhandle you can get
away with that step
only in the pan that type of thing is
far more responsible for real-world
violence than video games we know this
and before we get back to the main topic
here Donald Trump also mistakenly
referring to the Toledo shooting
yesterday instead of Dayton the shooting
of code of course was not in Toledo it
was in Dayton and you'll notice in this
clip Trump strange sniffing his back his
Mushmouth speech is back there's
something very odd about this if we are
able to pass great legislation after all
of these years we will ensure that those
who were attacked will not have died in
vain may God bless the memory of those
who perished in Toledo I may God protect
them may God protect all of those from
Texas to Ohio may God bless the victims
and their families may god bless america
thank you very much thank you weird that
this happens even when using a
teleprompter who knows the White House
has retro actively removed Trump's
mention of Toledo from the official
White House transcript of the speech so
anyway they're jumping on the videogame
bandwagon and I told you yesterday and I
will remind you other countries have
video games they have atheists they have
mental illness they have all the things
that we have that are often blamed for
shootings usually they have fewer guns
but they have no or almost no mass
shootings the way that we do so this is
a planned coordinated talking point
distraction how does Japan have almost
no gun deaths despite having just
explosive video game usage it is not
beyond a we can now say to say it a
different way
it is beyond any doubt that the
anti-immigrant rhetoric of this
president is having an effect and the
debate is over what level of an effect
is it having and the right has done two
things one is they've gotten on this
video game bandwagon the other is to
finally have Donald Trump men
white supremacy during his speech and
now Trump has actually said he condemns
white supremacy a white supremacist
which I commend him for I do to the
extent that I believe it but why did he
not condemn it
when white supremacists endorsed him in
2015 why did he play coy with it back
then and during 2016 and his campaign
what about after Charlottesville why has
it taken this long for Trump to finally
say it we know why because he's been
resisting it and now he's saying it
because he almost has no choice they are
up against the wall here the shooter
mentioned Trump in his manifesto Fox
News talked about a troubled young man
who had a manifesto which they won't
tell us the details of as Republicans
all go on national television and radio
and talk about video games this is
what's called BS and I don't even think
that they realize they're sort of
inadvertently pushing for an anti free
speech regulation of the content of
video games which they're normally
opposed to understand that if the full
conclusion of video games are to blame
is actually grasped as the cause here at
the tail end of that it's telling video
game makers what can or can't be part of
the video games that they make which is
fundamentally the opposite of what
Republicans have been advocating for
along the lines of free speech and
censorship all this time there was a
movement in the 90s about video games
and violence and to be clear I really
want to make sure people know this I
don't deny that there are effects of
violence in media to study this includes
the news of crimes on on the news
reports of crimes on the news better
said violence in movies violence in
video games but pretending now that the
connection is violence in video games
causes people to commit mass shootings
on the basis of white nationalist
anti-immigrant beliefs that's just
despicable and the most shameful part of
it is that they pretend that the point
of the guns that people own is
everything but committing violent acts
guns are for hunting guns are for
self-defense guns are for the craft of
cleaning them and understanding them
they're for target practice guns are for
everything other than violence there
no connection to violence but the video
games that's where the violence is and
video games are now a matter of life and
death truly disgusting and they may well
get away with it because no heinous act
we know this no heinous act will get the
gun fetishists to reconsider their point
of view they know this and that's why
they're hopping on this video game
talking point bandwagon now and it may
well work